Paul continuing on but it's actually an
extension of yesterday's talk on
and the death meditation and the unself.
Okay. Um,
we've been looking
at the same
spiritual problem, the selfieing problem
energetically,
but mostly from Naga's point of view.
Okay. But I but we mentioned yesterday's
the fruitful one. Okay.
But from NA's point of view, we've
talked about how monitor yourself for
tension and release the tension except
for what is keeping the structural
integrity of the spine. Okay, so we can
do the same thing with this technique.
Okay, that's what you're doing. Okay, I
can do the same thing if I have a desire
to get out just like a desire to throw.
That's the selfie aspect. Okay. If I'm
collapsing, that too is a kind of selfie
aspect. I keep the same posture
that I'm feeling. And you know, this is
a side motivation as I keep the same
posture. If I can release more than him,
then I'm controlling him. Okay, there
still is a marshall end to it. But
spiritually as UK, I let myself be
projected. Again, the one who can
project the most is the one who's the
most objectable. What I want you to do
is feel where the tension and the
desire,
all of that comes in as he slowly goes
through the motion. Okay? Do you
understand? Okay? So, let's do that.
Don't don't even take it to the throw.
Observe
yourself. Keep your spinal structural
integrity.
Get that arm out of the way.
Lock your lock your spine more. Your
spine is is is disconnecting from your
muscles. So stay there, please. Stay
there. Stay there. Don't move. Just ease
up a little, but don't move. Okay. Where
are his feet?
They're on the ground. You see that? So,
this broke.
Do you understand? Does everyone
understand that? Okay. So, Chris is
here. Okay.
And you got sorry you got all the way to
about here would you say? Okay. So the
only way that happens is the quad the
quad gate. See if I keep the the the
same uh
co relationship so that I can move him
and I let him move that you're going to
see that the foot is coming up. Okay.
There's no way that
this is a breaking of posture. Okay? No
different than he's he's pushing on me
and I'm breaking on posture. Okay? So,
try it again.
Bring that in. Let that inside foot come
up. Good. And release. Accept your
death.
If you fall, you fall. But they're not
trying to throw you. They're just giving
you the experience.
Okay. So, death meditation.
Uh, I mentioned
I I suppose at the beginning you'll have
to like actually imagine your death to
get you in there. Just like we say let
go of the tension
to feel the tissue drop. Although this
morning I told you the tissue could go
up that's not actually released. Okay.
So maybe at the beginning you got to
imagine
I'm dead. Okay. Sometimes you'll have to
go through
the Ruby truth. Your kids are not your
kids.
You have kids.
Um because you'll be thinking I can't
die now. I got to take care of these
kids.
things like that.
Um maybe even some some sadness might
creep in to your dying sad. Okay. But
ultimately what it is is that in the
same way that you're letting the force
pass through your gravity, you're
letting the force pass through your
identity.
Um,
and in the same way that you're not
contesting against that force, you're
doing the same thing. So, if I were to
put it poetically,
it it feels like in the same way I'm
trying to o open my hand and let
something drop out of it. I'm trying to
open myself to let myself fall away.
Okay. Um,
now what the does that mean? Okay.
But you're on you're on the Someone said
it to you. Okay. Um, so let's go through
it and let's find that level of
releasing. Okay. That and that level and
that and therein is the only place
acceptance as we mean it comes in. It's
the only place that non-resistance
actually comes in. Everything before
that is resistance and contestation and
non-acceptance. Okay. But we it's a
skill. So we have to progress for it.
Okay. All right. So, try this same
exercise again. And we'll go all the way
into the throw. Okay. Slow like this.
And you're monitoring yourself for
desires,
intentions, emotions, flexion,
nonflection, disconnection, all that.
Okay? Those are all selfie aspects.
Attempts to catch balance. Those are all
self aspects.
[Music]
Yes. Yes. I forgot. That's a huge one.
That's a huge one. We're trying to slow
my fall down.
Yeah, that's a very good one. That's
very common
breath. Did your breathing stop
even trying to fall? Trying to fall is
selfing too.
Monitor yourself
structural organization.
Okay. So we'll watch this one.
Same side.
Okay. Anyone see this selfie? Yes. Okay.
What where did how did it manifest? He
switched his hips so that way he would.
Okay. Good.
We're in the ballpark. That's where it
happened. That is part of it. Who can
find it before that one?
arm to kind
I can see that from back here. I don't
know about there.
The the motion wasn't uh synonymous with
what was doing. Yeah. Okay. So that's
and that's what allowed me to change my
hips. So there's the agency is in the
technique and he wasn't
you're not moving him is how I would say
it. Okay. So, if we come up and do this
forward away from the wall.
Okay. So, there's no there's no Look how
he went around her. Did you see that?
But her arm stayed here.
So, why' you go around
the technique? The technique. You don't
You don't do anything.
She has to do She has to do the tech.
I'm just here.
She'll never bring me around by going
that way. I just keep the organization.
That's what she did. You see that? When
I go like, "I'm supposed to go here."
Well, when you go there and you take
yourself there, that is the self aspect.
Okay. Try it again.
You don't fall.
They make you fall. You accept being
fallen.
You feel your breath all the You're the
hook.
[Music]
reach for the mat. So, reaching for the
mat and trying to brace and slow down
our fall is the same thing as grabbing
on. Okay. Um
because all the forces are not present,
right?
There's not there's there's no uh go
through projection here like like my
dashi are used to doing. Okay, cuz he's
going so slow. So I just lock
everything.
It should look like that. Okay, he
brought me around him. One leg is the
only leg that's being affected. There's
no inertia or centrifugal energy on the
other foot.
And I just land with the same structure.
My head is off the mat and I'm not in
hot oil. I don't reach and brace for the
mat. I don't hurry up and get the hell
off the mat. I just lay down at the
bottom and continue to release. Okay,
let's try it.
You only will have your outside hand for
your candy, which is different from what
you're used to. Not the inside hand.
refine your consciousness by dying.
You're already dead. So, you know, a
thing that we love in law enforcement,
we love uh Lieutenant Spears.
We actually have those guys from the
Veron Brothers come to our uh academy
and they'd speak to the recruits. We
also have the the guy from um
we were soldiers that that Vietnam unit
they come and talk to us. And the reason
that you know if you know Banner
brothers and those were real guys they
all did biography and got these
statements and things like that.
Um
There's one section there
where
for those who don't know the show, u
it's about the ally uh push into Germany
on uh D-Day off of Normandy. Okay. And
the show is about the um airborne that
that's there and doing this push.
And there's one part of the show where
they get halted and this an interesting
history because um depending which
American unit you ask
um they got halt. So if you ask this the
airborne they got halted
not because they were getting stalled by
the German resistance but because
uh Patton was behind and Patton was
wanted the propaganda of going ahead and
um Patton's defense argument was they
were surrounded but Airborne's defense
to that was we're always surrounded
we're airborne. Okay. So they did they
did not this this whole fight. So at
this moment they're told stop advancing
and dig some fox holes and wait and but
by this time there's a lot of urban
fighting and urban fighting is uh as you
guys saw in that video is absolutely
terrifying. Um,
us in law enforcement, we have people
that come from the military and when I
started in law enforcement, we didn't
have much military units exposed to
urban fighting and they would
immediately go, I can't believe you guys
freaking do this, okay? Because it is
crazy.
um from their point of view, especially
when we're not going to bomb the house
first from from the shore and then throw
grenades in it and then flashbangs, you
know, we're just going in with drywall.
Okay. Um
even different agencies will are not
used to this kind of stuff. So, Highway
Patrol kind of hangs out on the on the
roadways, right? And sometimes we get
backed by them and I remember we had um
home burglars in the house and they
would not come out and so we had to go
in and now we're searching him and we
had to call CHP. It was a giant mansion.
The CHP comes to back up and on point
and I'm searching around and we're we're
just doing our business. a bunch of
deputies and and one CHB guy. And then
um we're finding them and silently
looking them as we finding them more and
out we go. We're done. And then my
deputy partner, he's laughing up. He's
killing that CHP guy. I go, "What? What
do you mean?" He's he's all like he's
just freaking out how you're just
walking into these these corners
eventually and that you're not freaking
out. And I go, "Well, I freaked out when
that tra uh tanker truck spilled on the
highway and just looked like a movie
disaster." And I had no freaking idea
what to do. He was all calm. So that's
their bread and butter. This is our
bread and butter. Okay. So here they are
urban fighting. Foxholes
stop advancing.
And in this scene, one of the guys is
totally having um you know PTSD already.
And Spears is walking as a lieutenant.
He's checking on the men, making sure
they all have their fault where they're
going. He's literally just walking like
he's walking in the bar.
And he finally gets to the guy. He sees
him shaking and all freaking out. And um
he's all, you know, what's going on?
What's the matter? And the guy says, "I
don't want to die." And he's your
problem. you you have to realize you're
already dead. And that was Spear's
mindset into this thing and into this
nightmare. Okay? And that is part of the
warrior tradition. That is part of the
unself of all the mystical and aesthetic
traditions too. Um this is why they
always include pain. They always include
trial, physical trial, exhaustion. They
they never until modern times were this
comfortable
contemplating
meditating kind of thing. Okay. So here
we're just doing these little micro
acceptance. You're already dead. That's
how you line up. Okay. And you just let
yourself fall and stay dead as you're
going through. Don't cling to life.
And then stay dead at the bottom.
release at the bottom. Okay, try again.
There's absolutely no wrong way of
falling except taking control of how you
fall.
Don't unlock your body though. You have
to keep the spinal organization.
That's good. Bouching,
you're already dead.
Watch. Watch uh Ellie behind you. You
guys, you too.
Don't reach for the mat.
Okay, I got to stop you for a second.
You're already dead. Okay, but you're
not you're not done. Okay. You got to
still keep the the spinal integrity. You
guys understand? We're starting to get a
little sloppy on the spine. Okay. Try it
again.
No, you reach for him. You reach with
your left hand.
You're disconnected.
You're disconnected in the middle.
Relax.
So, what do we do? Our feet are on the
mat.
Come on. Disconnect. You understand?
Okay. Cuz what? Cuz now when your foot
is off the mat, you're more off balance.
Do you see? Okay. Come on.
You grabbed him.
Don't go. Don't go sleepy. It's not
surrendering.
It's not. You know what I mean? Okay.
Don't grab them.
Okay, change partners
and we'll pick up the pace. I'm not
saying go full speed, but we're going to
go faster than the last rep.
The practice is the same.
Don't grab up. Don't disconnect your
spine.
Don't brace on the mat.
Don't grab them.
Don't come up right away. Make sure all
your anxiety is gone. All your
anxietyy's gone.
We're not fighting each other.
Don't grab him, D Chris. Don't grab him.
Watch your other arm. Hook it around.
Don't grab him.
Good tail.
[Music]
Change tires and go
a little quicker. Not full speed.
I don't know. Rio, I think they have it
out for you.
Make sure he's coming around.
Don't grab them.
Don't Don't lean on him either. Okay.
Yeah. That's just as bad as just
grabbing him.
If And if you would just keep the circle
going, he wouldn't lean on you. Just
keep it going. Yeah, just keep it going.
[Music]
So that way probably could have walked
out. Okay. All right. Uh change partners
and kick it up. So you just move the arm
into boom. Move the arm into boom. Okay.
You're already dead.
That's it. First one kind of caught you.
Don't slink out. You got to keep that
spinal relation.
Your arm has
cuz that ring goes around you.
Come on. Throw.
Elbow down, palm up. Elbow down, palm
up. Elbow down, palm up. Yes.
You got to throw him. Good.
Yes.
Don't grab them. Don't slip your spine.
Okay. So, if
Because together we already said there's
this is what kaza is is energy work.
Okay. We have the spiritual aspect. We
have the energetic aspect. Okay. Say
energetic aspect. So it's mudra
oriented. You got to think broader.
Okay. We already said the mudra was
already in the grip very similar to the
zazan mudra. Okay. But their mudra is
also it doesn't need the actual contact
at the grid. It's the mudra is already
there now from different contact points.
You understand? And the
the components that make up the mudra
are also taking place within me. It just
concentrically repeats itself over and
over and over. So it's in me. It's at
the contact point. It's between us. Do
you understand? Okay. So the better the
other part of the mudra is, the better
the this side of the mudra is. Okay? So
in other words, if I have like a shitty
finger over here, no matter how much I'm
sending into this thumb, it's not going
to do it. It has to be equally on this
side. All right. So you're doing
fantastic. Okay. Come back up. And this
is your n.
And because Shawn here the
because Shawn is doing what he is
supposed to do,
we now don't have the bunkai shuffle
because he can now work on what he needs
to do. Okay. So here we go. And both
will do what they need to do. You need
to end in a solid relaxed state. You
need to accept the death. Okay. Try it.
You just go.
Yeah. Look at that. That's not even the
same Ryan. That's not the same. I don't
know who this new kid is, okay? That
just walked in because that was not You
can watch that video when you get home.
That's a different person. Okay? Because
this suit is a different.
What happens is when you feel the
connections going on and off as they try
whatever afflection in the fear of
trying to get out of it in the fear we
still are getting triggered by it we do
our usual thing we go into the
contestation okay instead of I'll just
go to the hamme
I mean that kind of thing um
and this takes us back You can really
only get as good as your training
partners are. Okay? Uh until you pass
them, then you can then now you're
better. You pull that guy up. So, a few
hammer fists to the face, but you just
stops burning. You know what I mean?
That's how the the boys were trained.
That's how Taylor was trained. Uh they
they cuz you're not out of it. So, you
thought you got out of it. You know what
I mean? Cuz you wouldn't accept what's
happening. Well, if that's the engine
you're working with, then your training
partner works against that engine. Let
me give you something you'd rather get
out of more hammer fish to the face.
Okay? You're going to keep connection
and just take the break.
Um, now all that said, that's for
training for us.
The um
the real person, the average person, not
not another person train in this kind of
energetics even somebody with a lot of
rank but they don't train at this level.
So we already mentioned that um just in
the decades that I've trained in BJJ
it's like a different art now um that is
repeated in that book I'm not the only
one saying it the very founders of the
art are saying it themselves okay it's
just something you know you notice right
away um they do a lot of contestation
and not contestation. They went
the way they catered to it was weight
categories, no strikes and um steroids
allowed. Okay, you got it. So, yeah, we
can make this work. Um
that level of skill or you can still do
what I'm about to tell you. Okay, people
that aggress automatically organize
their spine in their aggression. They're
not loose. So I think you had the system
of training. All the training goes to
staying loose because in the aggression
is comes the tension that solidifies
that whole body if you get it. Um and
that's actually what happens. So people
that are really aggressive, really
fighting, if you do the same stuff,
they're even lighter.
light to get even lighter because the
whole body turns into this freaking
board. Okay. U so it actually while it
makes it seem
I might be delusional because he was so
throwable, the actual asocial guy is
even more throwable because he's even
more tense. He's even more a lever.
Okay. So in my opinion, when we get you
at this level as we get at that level,
we're actually closer to the application
field than this slinky guy or this guy
who turns around because he's trying to
find his inside foot because he knows
sooner or later he's going to go down.
That's not what the social um attackers
know. They don't know that. Okay. Does
that make sense? Okay. Um could you feel
everyone looks a lot better. Um every
nam looked a lot better too because
every is able to do this now. But could
you feel as we worked our way here what
we were talking about this steeling
this broader thing tension escape
ignoring the instructions bracing on the
mat holding on
you you know what I'm talking about um
so that would be my long winded answer
to your your question okay and again
that's where the teacher comes in the
teacher can see the selfie and we might
not be able just like the teacher can
see the tension and we might not be able
to see it but that through the exercises
were brought to a conscious level where
now I can start working on it. Okay. All
right. We'll take another break.